a posé trois conditions la première
condition c'est le rythme de la réforme
parce que l'enjeu de l'acceptabilité
sociale est absolument essentielle dans
un climat social qui est extrêmement
tendu et donc nous proposons en fait
l'étalement de la mesure d'âge donc à 64
ans à horizon 2032 avec une pause enfin
une étape intermédiaire à 63 ans en 2027
donc étalement de la réforme ensuite
justice sociale et Éric Ciotti a réussi
à faire accepter l'idée de revaloriser à
1200 euros les pensions minimales avec
une avec comment dire un ciblage et sur
les retraités actuels et sur les futurs
retraités ça pour nous c'est absolument
non négociable et troisième condition
c'est évidemment la pénibilité et les
carrières